und nachdem wir dann prinz und
prinzessin gespielt haben sind wir ganz
schnell zurück gegangen trim von
prinzessin märchen
also ehrlich giotto man finde ich das
mag etwas von mir will erstmal der
unbedingt mit ihr zum drachenfels zurück
fehler der einzige der den weg ins dann
hat er den prinzen gespielt er hat mir
sogar angeboten mich vor der
einwanderungsbehörde zu verstecken falls
ich mal passt zu verbinden
das ist diesmal noch ganz klar was er
will
es gibt übrigens gar keine
einwanderungsbehörde in deutschland das
heißt glaube ich ausländerbehörde oder
so nur noch heißt eigentlich die ganze
zeit ausschau
und wie war es für euch
etwas kommt schon riesig bin ich deine
großmutter dieses gelaufen
was soll denn da überhaupt laufen
das sieht doch ein blinder das so
annehmen interessieren
wie kommst du voran
das ist schwierig
ich glaube auch dass ich nicht mag aber
da musst du mir aus der ausgehen
du musst dir zeigen dass du sie meist es
funktioniert das nicht
du musst dir ein zeichen geben sie
wartet darauf
mach es so wie ich
so wie du
weil ich ausgerechnet ihr vertrauen ich
denke deine beziehung weil ich weiß wie
es geht
es müssten sich besser als du wie man
zusammen macht
schaue mir das an es läuft super mit ihm
schuld war nicht zu übersehen dass wir
total auf sie stehst ich fass es nicht
du hast uns hierher geschleppt nur weil
du hier band treffen willst